Between roles like Harley Quinn, Tonya
Harding, and Sharon Tate — when you have
a part that requires an iconic diva, you call
Margot Robbie. But what happened on the set of
The Wolf of Wall Street that was too much even
for this megastar? Keep watching to find out.
During production on The Wolf of Wall Street,
Margot Robbie joined a long list of actors
who filmed love scenes they eventually regretted.
Playing Naomi Lapaglia, the fictional second wife
of millionaire stockbroker Jordan Belfort,
Robbie filmed a variety of sensual scenes.
“You don’t wanna be my friend?”
“We’re not gonna be friends.”
However, the scene that most stood out
for the Australian actress was one where
Naomi and Jordan, played by Leonardo
Dicaprio, make love on a bed of cash.
Like most film productions, fake
cash was used to film the scene,
and the bills — produced by famed movie
moneymaker RJR Props — left Robbie with an
unusual cautionary tale to share. In a 2017
interview with The Daily Beast, she warned:
"I got a million paper cuts on my back from all
that money! It's not as glamorous as it sounds.
If anyone is ever planning on having
sex on top of a pile of cash: don't."
Yep, you heard that right! Robbie suffered
battle scars from rolling around in money.
Apparently the texture of movie money
is different from the real thing, and
everyone on set that day found out exactly
how much of a difference a small change
in texture can make. In her interview
with The Daily Beast, Robbie reflected:
"Maybe real money is a bit softer,
but the fake money is like paper,
and when I got up off the bed, I turned
around to get my robe and everyone gasped.
I said, 'What is it?' And they
said, 'You look like you've been
whipped a million times. Your back is
covered in a thousand red scratches.'"
If only that was the height of excitement
during Robbie’s Wolf of Wall Street experience.
Turns out, Margot Robbie's uncomfortable
love scene with co-star Leonardo DiCaprio
was one of many that stuck with her after
the cameras stopped rolling. The Wolf of
Wall Street star also revealed to The Daily
Beast which scene was the most bonkers to film:
"Every single scene was absolutely insane.
Definitely the Quaalude scene. I remember
sitting there going, 'I will never,
ever film a scene like this again.'"
We doubt you’ve forgotten this once-in-a-lifetime
sequence, but if you need a refresher:
the “Quaalude scene” occurs in the hectic
final act of The Wolf of Wall Street,
when Jordan drives out to his country club to
make an important call. While on the phone,
he discovers the seemingly-expired Quaaludes
he took with Jonah Hill’s Donnie, were,
in fact, still active. As the effects of the
drugs kick in, Jordan realizes his shady business
dealings have gotten him in serious trouble,
and he springs into action to get himself out.
Over the course of a hysterical 10 minutes,
an extremely high Jordan crawls his way
back to his car, drives home, yells at an
equally high Donnie for double-crossing him,
and then saves Donnie as he starts
choking to death on a piece of ham.
Meanwhile, a pregnant Naomi is left
to watch and worry. It's no wonder
the scene left such a big impression on
Robbie. She recalled to The Daily Beast:
"I'm sitting there [as Naomi], eight months
pregnant, and Leo and Jonah are crawling around
trying to strangle each other and I had to try
not to laugh because they looked so ridiculous."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
Hollywood blockbusters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.